soy un hombre de ciencia un naturalista
llevamos los desiertos y sus paradojas
son quizá los elementos inherentes y la
vastedad esos paisajes que los evocan
desafiantes a las personas y a la
civilización misma
los desiertos aparentan ser grandes
vacíos sin embargo estos están repletos
de vida
particularmente para aquellos que
sabemos en dónde buscar
[Música]
[Aplausos]
amo la vida en todas sus formas
pero aquello que más amo del desierto
sobre todo
son sus peces
los desiertos por definición contienen
poca agua sin embargo muchos desiertos
del planeta hospedan ecosistemas
acuáticos interesantísimos
a manera de islas
que paradójicamente albergan una gran
cantidad de diversidad acuática
las especies que habitan generalmente
son endémicas raras de naturaleza
realista
y de distribución muchas ocasiones
restringida a un manantial o un cuerpo
de agua
y en muchas de estas ocasiones también
habitan en una situación de existencia
precaria
el bolsón de los muertos se localiza en
el corazón del desierto chihuahuense
cabe decir que este gran desierto antes
de ser un desierto fue un lugar donde
había abundante agua y vegetación
hace 10.000 años durante el pleistoceno
estaban en enormes llanuras
animales impresionantes como mastodontes
bisontes manadas de caballos negros
leones a frases y tigres dientes de
sable
[Música]
los invito los siguientes 30 segundos
hagamos un viaje al pasado hace 10.000
años
y tratemos de conocer cómo se escucharía
estar parados en lo que es el estado de
chihuahua en estas grandes llanuras
cerremos los ojos 30 segundos
[Música]
bien
pues esto era méxico en el pleistoceno
hace más de 10.000 años
las grandes lagunas donde bebían agua
estos animales
permitieron que prosperarán no sólo los
grandes mamíferos sino también una gran
diversidad de especies acuáticas que
habitaron en estas durante largos
periodos de tiempo
hasta que el clima comenzó a cambiar y
las condiciones de este sitio comenzaron
a tornarse cálidas y secas
las enormes palio lagunas se fueron
reduciendo poco a poco hasta quedar tan
solo relictos
más reales enormes y pequeños oasis
rodeados de arena de arcilla y de
vientos sedientos
el aislamiento en el que quedaron
atrapadas estas especies acuáticas las
llevó a evolucionar y tuvieron que
desarrollar adaptaciones únicas para
poder resistir y sobrevivir en un
ambiente tan hostil
por miles de años estos oasis estos
refugios fueron suficiente hogar para
estas especies
hasta que llegamos los seres humanos
llegó el progreso y con ello las
potentes bombas de succión
con la tecnología necesaria para extraer
del subsuelo millones de metros cúbicos
a velocidades que ya no permiten la
recarga de los acuíferos
y que junto con la extinción de estos
acuíferos están condenado a muerte los
oasis que tenemos en el desierto
prueba de ello fue la situación con la
que nos topamos en el bolsón de los
muertos preocupados por esta situación
de desaparición de nuestros cuerpos de
agua desérticos nos dimos a la tarea de
ir a este sitio y tratar de determinar
cuál es el estado de las especies que
solamente habitaban en el bolsón
hagamos un viaje al bolsón de los
muertos
[Música]
cuando llegamos ahí lo que encontramos
fue preocupante
de los seis cuerpos de agua que
reportaba la literatura científica
solamente uno
cuyo nombre es el ojo solo quedaba con
vida
y de acuerdo a los análisis que
realizamos nos dimos cuenta que le
quedaban no más de 10 años de existencia
preocupados por la situación de las
especies que allí se encontraban pues
tuviesen una exploración satelital y
localizamos un sistema de géiseres no
muy lejos de ahí a unos 20-25 kilómetros
cuyos escurrimientos prometían ser aptos
para el establecimiento o la
construcción de una moderna arca de noé
a donde pudiéramos llevar a las especies
y evitar su extinción en el 2003 se
conseguimos algo de financiamiento del
fondo del príncipe de abu dhabi y
mohamed bin zayed del consejo de los
peces del desierto y más tarde se sumó
el fondo georg meier y nos financiaron
los estudios necesarios para evaluar la
viabilidad de construir un refugio en
este sitio y trasladar a las especies
del ojo solo para evitar su extinción
por fin en el 2014 iniciamos con el
proyecto
la primera labor fue colectar ejemplares
para evaluar el estado de salud y ver la
condición en la que se encontraban las
diferentes especies que conformaban el
complejo
pensamos a los individuos y nos topamos
para nuestra sorpresa con un amigo un
viejo conocido que estaba ya ha
reportado extinto desde hace muchos años
en la cocina de chihuahua cambiar el
archivo
encontramos una población muy sana de
otro tipo de pez el cachorrito carbonero
también exclusivo de estos cuerpos de
agua y nos topamos con que solamente
quedaban 50 ejemplares adultos en todo
el planeta de la carpeta boca grande
esto nos colocaba frente un dilema
por un lado sabíamos que la mortandad
en las carpetas cuando los sacamos del
agua y las tratamos de modificar su
hábitat se mueran los pocos minutos son
sumamente difíciles de manejar
por otro lado la probabilidad de que
estuviéramos equivocados con nuestras
predicciones y que lo consoló no secará
entonces nos vimos enfrentados frente a
cuatro escenarios que nos competían
el primero quisiéramos el ridículo los
peces nos morían en el camino y el ojo
solo no secará imagínense la bronca en
las que cometíamos segundo
que nos moviésemos a los peces y se
secará el ojo sol en cuyo caso también
seríamos responsables de omisión de no
haber hecho nada de haber tenido en las
manos haber evitado la excepción de
estos peces
el tercero que los peces se murieran y
se secará el ojo solo después de haber
hecho todos los intentos bueno pues
habríamos hecho todo lo posible y el
cuarto que todo nos saliera bien
por cierto el cachorrito carbonero es el
compañero de la carpeta de bocagrande
la existencia de la carpeta y toda su
fauna acompañante está en peligro
y teníamos que tomar una decisión
nos juntamos todo el equipo de liberamos
debatimos y ya ves que nos pusimos de
acuerdo a favor los que estaban en
contra y todos tenían razones válidas
lógicas y legítimas
un problemón
yo me tocaba lidera el equipo viendo que
iba a ser imposible que nos pusiéramos
de acuerdo tomó un respiro les dije que
me dejaran solo y les pedí que me
dejaran ir a platicar ya consultarlo con
los peces
[Música]
entonces camine hacia el ojo solo
me senté y comencé a buscar a los peces
pronto se acercaron los cachorritos
carboneros muy curiosos y más adelante
llegó un macho carpita mosca grande
[Música]
y parecían estar muy interesados en lo
que tenía que decirles
[Música]
presente los observé y observaron
y les expliqué la situación
y me dio la impresión de estar muy
enojados y con toda la razón
no les gustó lo que les dije
[Música]
pero tuve la impresión que me decían
pues que su especie de unidad
y que aspiraban a lo que aspiramos del
planeta
alcanzar el bienestar vive bien y
perpetuarnos en el cielo
y por lo tanto estaban dispuestos a
jugársela
y acompañarlos en esta aventura
[Música]
iniciamos las maniobras
conectamos toda la mañana y en la tarde
siguiendo los protocolos muy
curiosamente estaban listos para iniciar
el viaje hacia el nuevo estilo la
compañía
[Música]
llegamos
lamentablemente el camino se nos
murieron un número importante ejemplares
liberamos a los que sobrevivieron y nos
quedamos con la esperanza y que ojalá
lograran adaptarse a su nuevo hogar
y colonizar el nuevo recurso
seguimos viendo y unos par de años más
tarde nos topamos con la siguiente
noticia
que tuvimos al cuidado de grabar y
registrar
hoy es enero 20 del 2017 estamos en el
ojo solo con lo que fue el ojo solo
estamos documentando prácticamente la
extinción de este ecosistema era el
último
donde habitaban las especies de manera
natural definidos con tina les
y en la costa de chihuahua carlos
chihuahua
sabíamos que estaba seca entonces
algunos años
no pensamos que fuese a ser tan rápido
pues estamos parados justo donde se
hicieron las colectas al refugio que se
construyó los calientes bueno pues la
buena noticia es que poco después unos
años pues regresamos seguimos
monitoreando las carpetas les gustó
mucho su casa se empezaron a reproducir
y hoy hay cientos de carpetas lo que
grandes en su refugio esperando a que
tengamos la oportunidad los recursos de
financiamiento para poderlo ampliar
es de humanos cometer errores
pero si nos escuchamos seguimos a
nuestra conciencia
difícilmente cometemos equivocaciones
pues aunque las cosas no salgan mal
tendremos la certeza de que hicimos todo
lo que estaba en nuestras manos
la equivocación es consecuencia de no
seguir lo que es correcto
y de perder el rumbo que nos marca
nuestra conciencia
intervenimos o dejamos que la naturaleza
se de su curso la vida está repleta de
retos y de coyunturas pero si nos
escuchamos seguimos a nuestra conciencia
tomaremos buenas decisiones
solo tomando riesgos calculados
en conciencia y sin titubear podremos
tomar buenas decisiones
pues aun cuando es de humanos que
cometamos errores lo que importa al fin
del día es estar bien con uno mismo y
esa es mi receta personal para poder ser
mayor
gracias
[Música]
[Aplausos]